Віталік, документи і гроші взяв?
Я Ковальов Сергій.
49 років, одружений, двоє дітей.
Село Великі Копані.
Слюсарем працював на заводі.
У нас тут в радгоспі був цех.
Я ходив на роботу.
Я боявся піти з роботи, вважав,
що повинен там заробити пенсію і все решта.
Потім це переважило,
стало приносити більше задоволення
і більше грошей.
І я зрозумів, що мені в ось цьому всьому комфортніше.
Як на базар приїдемо, головне правило —
знайти найкраще місце.
Стати так, щоб найгарніше і найвидніше.
Щоб всі бачили, всі підходили, всі через тебе йшли.
Не буває так, що завжди виграєш:
буває іноді, втрачаєш, а буває, і виграєш.
Так само і вони: виграють, втрачають, тобто це такий
постійний пошук рівноваги.
Добридень! Продаж, закупки?
Ви когось везете?
Ні, заїжджаємо.
Питають в американського мільйонера:
як ви розбагатіли і стали мільйонером?
Він відповідає: на смітнику
знайшов брудне яблуко, помив,
продав, купив два брудних, знову помив,
продав, купив три брудних, купив, продав.
А далі у мене помер дідусь мільйонер
і залишив мені спадок.
У моїй ситуації спадку не залишилось.
Я мив яблука до кінця.
[сміється]
Тобто доки не намив на ось це все.
Отакі справи.
Справа у тому,
що не знаєш, скільки заробиш.
Іноді, буває, вкладаєш, можеш навіть все вкласти.
Я, коли будував ці теплиці, то вклав усе.
Тобто я до наступного року залишився зовсім без грошей.
Тобто вклав усе, все, що було.
Ми все, в принципі, пробували садити.
З капустою виходить найкраще.
Тому капусту і садимо.
— По чому капуста?
— 21 гривня.
— А забрати?
— Скільки забрати? Все? Тоді по 20.
— По чому капуста?
— 21 гривня.
— А за скільки віддаси?
— За 20 віддам.
У нас тут перший фактор — тепліше.
У нас вдосталь води, вода досить близько.
Тепло, бо таки південь.
Бо Крим — теж південь, але в Криму немає води.
Вони там від каналу залежать, а у нас води вдосталь.
І, скажімо, у нас тут немає промисловості.
Городами займаються всі, це не хобі.
Це вже, напевно, такий стиль життя, інакше не зможеш.
Ринок живе за своїми ринковими законами.
А базар живе зовсім без законів.
Нас влаштовує, трохи поступились
людині у ціні, ну це таке діло.
Коли питають — ну як так — то це життя таке,
якщо 20 років проживеш,
то ти вже всіх тут знаєш, і всі тебе знають.
Якось це вже просто.
І так щодня з початку.
Батьківщину не обирають,
та і змінювати мені не дуже хотілось.
Я тут виріс, живу, мене всі знають.
Часом бувають думки,
коли хтось виїжджає, що я не зміг би.
Мені це все настільки близьке, рідне.
Своє місто, живеш так, і все.